people of the internet's retro recontour
here i'm just a dad who loves games in
the stories they tell welcome back to
harry potter and the prisoner of azkaban
where we finally have found a couple of
dung bombs where i believe we should be
able to use those to sneak past the
troll and hopefully get back into
gryffindor tower
i'm like what am i saying here
gryffindor tower i do not remember that
part of the book so i think that is a
completely original part here uh they've
got they've got trolls and then they're
just you know calmly standing guard
looking out for serious black
dumbledore's like look you know what
we've already got dementors on the
grounds the ministry sending them
we might as well bring some trolls into
you know let's bring the trolls
have the trolls keep a lookout
oh you know what i want to test though i
want to test if i switch to ron see last
time i totally remembered i'd completely
forgotten that ron has this special
ability for some reason that he's the
only one who can search bookcases so i
could have been searching these
bookcases all this time and apparently
that's how you find dung bombs and looks
like we found some birdie bop beans and
then i think a cauldron cake there and
it looks like another birdie bob bean
but i i found that kind of at the tail
end of last last uh the last episode
and it just so happens that dung bombs
are what we need to get by the troll so
we found three of those and now back to
the grand staircase we go all right so
it looks like we have to equip the dung
bombs just like we do
any other spell or any other
item like the wigan well potions so i'm
going to go ahead and get that ready put
that on x here and then make our way to
the top
i wonder if i guess ron's the only one
who can use them too probably
alright so here we go let's make our way
back over to gryffindor
or at least trying to get around to
gryffindor because you can't get in
right there that's the fat ladies
corridor but they have locked it down
i'm assuming because they've discovered
sirius black
is in the castle
and now we're gonna need to try and
figure out how to use these dunk bombs
trolls can be distracted by the smell of
dung bombs so
like let's see do i just
oh geez
well that's not good i don't want him
way over here
can i pick it back up
oh wait
okay hold on
this is gonna be a little bit more
complicated than i thought
okay let's try to go right here maybe we
have to get it really close to him
so i'm gonna try to get him to like
maybe come over in this little area
right here
okay now
there he goes he's checking it out
come on explode
it did it exploded just in time are
there more trolls
doesn't look like it right there
what what
no
no way
oh no way he discovered me over there
oh and of course ron wait
oh my goodness you guys
oh my goodness i really should have paid
more attention in the early parts of the
game
i just keep forgetting about the unique
abilities now where does this lead
wait what we got the mirror viewer said
shortcut to the fourth floor oh my gosh
so many shortcuts see they really did
there were so many things in this game
that they did really really well
[Music]
all right let's see can we
that's a page in some kind of uh
i think it's this book hold on right
is it the folio brew tie no i don't
think actually wait i think it might be
i think it might be another page in that
i don't know because we've got
wow we've got a lot in here ghoul
fireseed bush fairy dragonfly
doxie
chis purple
billywig dementor okay so
and then
three out of three on the fairy wings
okay
all right let's back out of here and
let's see where this leads okay shortcut
to the fourth floor i don't think we
want to take that right now
oh but then i'm kind of tempted i i
don't want it to be one of those that's
like
you can't get back up through this way
but i'm gonna try it anyway i gotta find
out okay so i bet if we go down
oh no it's just normal steps okay
perfect i was thinking i bet if we go
down here then we won't be able to get
back up but
yeah i'm not gonna mess with you guys
i'm just gonna go this way and see where
this leads
worthwhile history of magic all right i
don't want to deal with that right now i
want to go back i want to try to focus
on
getting past this troll first i think i
had done it the right way by where we
where we have positioned him i expected
it to at least stun him for a you know a
couple seconds but
it seemed like as soon as it exploded he
was just he was just done with it i mean
he just immediately
started coming after me again do i full
pindo on any of them no i do not
all right let's go ahead and equip up
flupindo i want to see if this uh
little cauldron has anything that we can
can use
yup it did but it made it very difficult
to lock on
just one bean
just one bean that time all right so
let's switch back to ron because i think
we're back up to
two dung bombs now
all right so it's gonna be over this way
and i think i saw another troll like
once i get past this first one
i'm almost positive i saw another one
yeah
the next area
all right so what's gonna put you right
see i don't know if that'll catch him
like if he'll
i would i would love to put it in this
corner right here but i don't know if
that will be like close enough to him
so here's where i kind of put it last
time like right
here
now like how distracted is he can i just
yeah i think i can just completely
all right go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go
yeah right here i was like i think i saw
another troll
your gentleman do and put this one
right here
and run around this way
no idea where i'm going there's a
treasure chest right here you guys
already know you've watched me play this
enough i have to go for the chest but
it's on this side we gotta be quick
good
at least it's a wizard card so even if i
do get caught it's it was kind of
kind of worth it
you've completed the beast card set 20
points for griffin dole
wait what is that up there
it's giving me a lock on
oh dude i'm in trouble i don't like this
we've got yet another troll okay let's
let's pause for just a second let's take
a look at the beast that we got
take a look at the completed set
all right so it said we completed the
one for beasts
all right so we had the imp we had the
doxie we had the bowtruckle and now we
have the billy wig has a long thin sting
that causes giddiness followed by
levitation dried billywig stings are
used in a variety of potions
cool that's interesting actually all
right so
and then we unlock this one for the
gnome as well a common garden pest
whoops
the gnome lurks in holes in the ground
and may run out and attempt to trip up
the unweary traveler can be ejected from
the garden by swinging it in circles and
flinging it over the garden wall
that's right if you played harry potter
in the uh chamber of secrets then you
know that all too well
all too well one of the more fun mini
games in chamber of secrets all right i
think i'm out oh am i out of
okay i thought i was out of dunk bombs
but it looks like i may have one more
dude i do not like how he's looking at
me though over there
i really don't like it i don't like it
one bit
all right so i think i'm gonna try to
just sneak around
wow frames frames
okay
oh my goodness there's two more
this is ridiculous
oh i don't think i have to and i'm
definitely going to need two
oh no i don't have any i don't have any
i'm totally out right now i'm out right
now can ron search these bookcases
you can come on
come through come through all right we
got one now
okay at least the game senses that hey
you definitely need some here so here
you go
well give me one more
[Music]
all right can i get this close to him
dude what i'm what i'm dreading is like
if i get caught now do i have to make it
all the way back through this whole area
all right so let's kind of get a plan on
this one before we go i think i'm gonna
try
oh man this one's tough
i feel like i'm gonna try to kind of get
to his right
and maybe put it over here like in in
that corner right there
i mean i can't go too far up because he
might see me and then try to sneak
behind him
from there
maybe maybe drop one like right in front
of that statue over there oh my gosh
it's a bloody baron
dude i just noticed he was up there is
that a statue or is that actually him
just being super still
what the heck i'm pretty sure it's a
statue
oh that is so weird okay all right let's
see if this is gonna work
i'm gonna try to get right about here
all right so he's he's
checking out that one
no
see i have to hurry because the other
one is right behind me though
oh no you guys it makes you do it all
again
oh it makes you do it all again that's
what i was afraid of
all right well hopefully we can search
and get a couple of them here
nice
all right so at least they're they're
fairly easy to find
and they do give you some bookshelves
right here before it but man i do not
want to have to keep doing this
oh yeah we already did that
why does that reset
[Music]
why does that reset that makes no sense
for that to reset
oh we only have two i'm pretty sure
[Music]
got a couple more in here though that we
can search
i feel like they replaced a lot of the
so in chamber of secrets you could
interact like flopindo dude you could
just blast everything like all these
little statues and you can in this game
too but it doesn't really do a great job
of locking on and they usually only give
you like one item if anything
this game it seems like they kind of
replaced that with having the
bookshelves searchable by ron but
honestly that gets a little more
frustrating to me i i think oh dude can
i actually search all of these
bookshelves oh he can alright so we
should be able to max out
easily on these we've got four out of
five right now
all right and since we can find them so
readily available
maybe that will give us a chance to kind
of okay there we go five of five let's
just kind of experiment a bit
yeah see i i wanna like
throw it way over here but i feel like
if i get too close
he's going to see me and if i'm not
close enough like we dropped one
our very first attempt
all right now come
go on go go go go go
and you're around all right
now this one
drop right here
yeah i'm pretty sure that like totally
distracts them for a bit
because i was i was right in front of
him and he didn't
he didn't really seem to care
all right now this is the tricky one
this is the tricky one because you've
got two kind of back to back right here
that we're gonna have to get
so we're definitely gonna need him to
move
so we can't i mean there's no way
that one though
maybe maybe i shouldn't try to do it so
quickly like maybe i i get past this one
and then basically the point where i'm
at right now maybe i get there but on
the other side of the bookshelf and then
just kind of hang out there
and then let let this one here on that's
closest to me right now let him reset
and then go from there let's let's try
that
all right so i'm gonna toss you right
here okay there he goes
all right now
nice okay
all right let's go ahead and search this
i mean you might as well right
now that i know ron can do this
okay so he oh dude i thought he was just
gonna keep going and turn around
oh that would have been insane all right
so
you can really go either way with this
guy
but i also don't want to re-alert the
other one
so i think oh man this is tough
i think i'm gonna kind of go right here
drop it right there
oh they're both going after it just run
just right just run just run
oh and we're gone we're out of here fat
ladies corridor let's go
finally dude oh my goodness
all right i would not want to do that
again that was not fun it was
interesting but not fun just please let
me in
there's neville what's wrong
i lost my list of passwords and serious
blank must have found sir duggan
just let him in professor mcgonagall is
so furious with me that she's forbidden
anyone to give me the password
hang on for tuna major
my pleasure
what a night
i'm sorry i just want to turn in yeah
you always do that ron
it's like uh a literal
well not literal because we know sirius
black's true identity but at least at
this point they're like a murderer is
breaking in trying to kill you you know
what i'm tired though
i think i'm just gonna go to bed not
worried at all
not worried even the slightest so yeah
just gonna turn in for the night
if you wish to stop exploring it in the
day yeah i know you guys always love to
force you love to just rush to the end
of the day but honestly i don't think
there's really anything else i want to
do at this point
i do let's double check and make sure
i'm pretty sure it's the dragon hide
gloves that we were after last time
yeah dragon had gloves last seen oh
that's why i couldn't find them last
time i just checked on that floor but it
actually says in the defense against the
dark arts classroom i'm not sure that
there's much to do you actually have to
go into the classroom all right but i
think we are ready to go ahead and end
the day so let's see what tomorrow
brings
for many nights no one slept well
gryffindor tower feared the return of
sirius black
throughout the castle rooms were
searched and security was tightened but
the elusive black remained at large
and much to ron and hermione's concern
there was no sign of scabbers or crook
shanks either
uh-oh i'm just saying that it's very
weird that the nice cabbage goes missing
getting close to the end game now
okay ron you've made your point i'm as
worried as you are
but right now we're missing something
else
potion ingredients and we haven't got
much time before professor snape expects
us in class
okay they did another kind of
interesting thing with this version of
the game and in terms of how they handle
classes so
that's that is the
what third at least the second but i
think the third potion class of it so
it's kind of like
they make the classes recurring in this
one
which
i don't believe you know that you know
what they might they might have had some
recurring ones in the previous games too
but
um i don't know this one just feels
feels a little bit different to me
okay let's see they don't tell us where
to go
all it said was the type of potion the
gir collect ingredients for the girding
potion
all right maybe once we kind of head out
here they'll
give us a little bit more guidance
possibly
hermione i'm looking at you anything
anything
it is day now as well so we could we
could try to go by the defense against
the dark arts classroom and see if we
could find the uh
dragon height gloves
it's so quiet like it's just eerily
quiet in the common rooms
that's yet another thing i think could
be really cool in hogwarts legacy is
just for that that common room to feel
alive you know
where it's not just like like it's kind
of just dead when you walk into that one
homework
who are you you look like you're way
older than me dude shouldn't you be
going outside to get your potions
ingredients okay outside i have to count
on the slytherin here to actually give
me an idea of where where we're supposed
to go
okay finally hermione there we go that
was the hint we were looking for see
every now and then they actually do
give you something constructive oh wait
but now see i can't i gotta remember
that
oh wait this is the place that was
locked earlier isn't it
okay sir cadugan has moved there now be
careful as you go on your way
for i must stay here to protect this
most strategic hallway i'm gonna open
this again because i'll bet he can help
us
all right so yeah this is the one i
already found
i really wish it would stay open
i'm just not good at all with directions
so anything that like gives me a visual
indicator that hey you've already uh
opened this you don't need to open it
again
would be very much helpful but
oh dude are they going to lock all these
classrooms now
please tell me defense against the
darkhearts isn't locked
oh they totally are they all are
because i really wanted to try and go
looking
for the
dragon high gloves
like can the game not tell that i'm i'm
heading that direction
i mean just relax hermione
just relax do you think they'll ever
catch serious black
ron i don't think terry needs reminding
about him like that like that's cool
that's good like just that banter that
conversation i like that oh here's
hacker right here he's actually inside
i'll find out what they're going to do
about buck beat later today
just hope it'll be all right
sorry i'm just so worried would you want
to ask me we need to get some flying
seahorses
and are you gonna elaborate oh still
stuck on those doxy eggs
you'll find them in their nests you'll
have to grab the eggs using that carpe
retractum spell oh
take some antidote with you
still can't get no flying seahorses what
you want to do is find the boathouse
near the lake then use that carpe
retractum spell on them to pull them out
the water go steady though pull too hard
and you lose them don't dragonflies
hover near shallow pools
okay he said if you pull too hard you'll
lose them carpe retract them i think is
what we have to use for both of those
and man how crazy is it that it's uh
it's at the boathouse
given what we know
takes place at the boathouse
in harry's seventh year
just before the big battle of hogwarts
all right so i guess we head this way
i i told you guys i'm terrible with
directions we haven't really been out
okay we have to find buckbeak all right
so buckbeak is going to help us i'm
really hot in these ropes
[Music]
i'm really hot in these robes yeah it
would be nice if we could uh
wait why do we have to find buckwheat
when i can just oh no these things again
oh no that's different
okay do i stun first
all right we need to stun all of these
as many as we can i think
and then go for the carpe okay finally
got that one
are we just literally like murdering
these doxies to get their eggs
dude this game is kind of brutal to the
magical creatures right
oh man
last time it was the uh
the fairy wings right
at least we didn't have to take their
lives but
the doxies were just like uh yeah
you're a pest and we are
is he like deflecting it what in the
world
oh well i think he totally was all right
look i'm not worried about the antidote
for you i'm sorry
just relax
first i'm going to collect these
okay this is the thing
okay
i need some antidote
why did it not give me that one
i've been poisoned
i need some antidote
why is it not giving them to me
[Music]
what
oh my goodness what did i do wrong
is that the thing where hagrid was
saying he had to be nice and gentle or
something
oh but again like no visual indication
they just disappeared i guess we have to
come back
maybe we have to come back later and
hopefully that will
reset i have no idea
[Music]
oh it's not reset right now so
not good not good
okay here's hagrid's hut is buck beak
nearby
because they did say we would need
buckwheat's help yeah there's bug beak
oh yep gotta make sure we bow can't
forget can't forget
even though bug beak knows us and buck
beak's cool with us
we still have to stand in front here
give him the little bow
all right and then we can ride
press and hold be oh my goodness no i
did not want to hop off
[Music]
oh really i just bowed come on don't
make me bow again
oh buckbeak do we really have to go
through this every time clearly you know
me buckbeak you know me
all right here we go okay so
let's look for the beacon of light we
know we need the boathouse
all right so it's kind of like cutting
me off
[Music]
oh no it didn't cut me off i thought it
was not going to let me go this way
come on buck b come on
dude imagine imagine doing this in
hogwarts legacy
we
and we already know we know it's
confirmed we are going to literally be
able to just fly around the hogwarts
grounds
on the back of a hippogriff on a
broomstick you guys
i just i can't wait man can't wait
it's gonna be so epic
just so epic like even if like let's
just say
like even if the combat's bad
even if the story is not great
just the saving grace will be just the
fact that if if exploring hogwarts is
fun
if they just managed to nail that i mean
that alone would be
would make for an incredible experience
but hopefully they're able to nail
everything i mean i hope so i have high
hopes that's for sure all right but i'm
kind of confused right now because uh
flying around i don't see a boathouse
[Music]
and i don't even see any of the oh wait
wait wait there it is there it is
there's our little beacon
that's what we were needing the beacon
of light
all right so i don't think we can land
over there though so let's see where
should we land with buckwheat maybe
right here
all right put on the brakes
all right nicely done buck beak
okay let's dismount oh dude there's a
treasure over here
let's go got to be another wizard card
right
got to be another wizard card they're
not going to put a random birdie bop
bean way over here are they
[Music]
oh another one of those things
all right
somebody told me what those were in the
comments on one of these early videos
and i totally forgot
i want to say it was like a page in the
uh folio brew tie book maybe
let's see because i i definitely
remember us having all of those wait
dragonfly might be new
dragonfly might oh hippogriff is
definitely new eye contact should be
maintained when approaching hippogriff
bowing shows good intentions if the
hippogriff returns the greeting it is
safe to draw closer
yep too bad our boy malfoy didn't listen
to that
too bad malfoy didn't just listen can we
go in right here actually i didn't think
so but i was just curious before we head
down this way all right to the boathouse
let's go
i wonder if buckwheat could have landed
over if we had we had flown straight
down there with buckwheat would we have
been able to land
[Music]
also ron and hermione no idea what
they're doing no idea
[Music]
oh my goodness to play
flying seahorse fishing press a dude i
did not know this was a thing
i did not know this was a thing
all right so carpe retract them
okay to leave no i don't want to leave
use your spell to catch and drag out of
the lake don't pull too hard okay so we
gotta do kind of a
[Music]
there we go oh that's cool
that like this mechanic actually like
let's see oh yeah this one works
perfectly
this is nice i like this instead of just
being able to like pull all the way back
you actually just have to pull the the
left stick about halfway down
all right i don't think there's any
point in getting extra so i'm just gonna
go ahead and press a
and then i think now
we'll need to go back and get whatever
the uh
other ingredients were that we needed
there was that one more that we needed
the i think it was a doxie egg right
to play flank see why is that not going
away
finally okay we don't need to play it
again hold on let me double check
we double check i think the ingredients
go to hermione
no hold on where do they go
or do they hold on it they just appear
right here so yes we got the three
flying seahorses we just need uh one
more doxie egg
and we definitely need to do
we need to have harry because we need
carpe retract them
copay retract him
to get that last egg
like see if you go back that section
with the eggs like that's that's a
perfect example of
just the mechanics being totally unclear
like i know
i think hagrid talked about being
careful with the sea horses and i think
he may have mentioned something with
with uh the eggs too but
it's like they just disappeared like it
gave the game gave me no indication
wait how do where did buck be go dude
how do we get back over there
where we need to be
oh great
[Music]
all right well buckbeak is just collect
more doxy eggs bailed on us yes hermione
i know we need another doxie egg okay
that's a dead end right there
let's see if we can go this way
[Music]
yeah it was just like two back to back
which i i was doing the exact same thing
that i did for the first one
what is this area
okay here we go dude i mean this is just
such a wide open
[Music]
yeah no i know ron
hey glad we came this way though another
chest
and possibly another wizard god
dude i think i hear a bunch of students
or it sounds it sounded like a crowd
somewhere all right let's go to
back to our book here
uh
we already had two
was it is it wizards maybe we already
had merlin we already had glanmore we
already had edgar stroger
yeah we had all of those
i know we had the two goblins i know we
had the hag i know we had the two giants
i think it might be a classical beast
we had giant squid it's unicorn we did
not have the unicorn the unicorn is a
shy creature and generally avoids human
contact it is more likely to let a witch
come near it than a wizard and casting
magic spells may frighten it off its
blood has highly
magical properties
okay so another wizard card down
and i don't i wonder if we need a fourth
ingredient just says collect ingredients
for the girding potion i bet after we
get the eggs then it's gonna have like
one more that they throw out there oh by
the way you need this one too
but i don't know they haven't mentioned
yeah they just keep talking about the
doxie eggs
oh wait what is this right here
what do we have in here
[Music]
oh this might be another spot to do the
to do dogs
but how can we get them out of the air
oh no we need something with the
dragonflies too
how can we get them out of the air well
hermione i bet it might have something
to do
i'll do we need to use a potion on her
as well
might have something to do with the
little statue right there all right
let's go ahead and do a wiggin weld on
there as well before we
[Music]
all right health replenished and let's
also
get her the window i know it's just so
it's so versatile
dude this spell like how it travels slow
it's so weird
oh my goodness a dragonfly
all right we got one
we just need to keep doing it like when
they get close
oh come on
they were right there we could have
gotten both
all right come back here he comes here
he comes here he comes now oh it's not
gonna get him
it's got a little wind up to it so i
think we need to cast it like right now
oh come
i'm on gonna spam
no
all right all right wait wait wait here
comes the other one come on come on come
on come on you gotta start going now
i think we might get this one yes okay
there we go
all right you know what just spam it
again spin it again get the next one
oh he's already gone dude
now right when like right when he starts
heading this way
or not because he flies incredibly
ridiculously slow
what
okay when he's when he's about halfway
to me then
okay wait for it wait for it wait for it
wait for it now
oh he do he like
oh he dodged away so quickly
all right so not halfway but like right
there
nice okay that's it we have all the
dragonflies we need all right so turned
out there was another ingredient
but now we need one more of the eggs
which i believe we go this way
get back out to the hagrid's hut area
i still cannot believe buck beat just
totally
bug me just gone buppy's like you expect
me to hang around here no i don't think
so i'm not gonna wait for you
as far as i know there's no way to
summon buckbeak so we just have to run
we have to walk all the way back around
but you know what exploring the hogwarts
grounds
it's hard to complain it's hard to
complain now obviously it's it's a very
dated look
seeing this in
2022 the game does not work
great
this one i'm actually running uh every
now and then i'll get a question people
asking uh what what am i playing on i
mean obviously they can see the gamecube
but they wonder if it's an emulator or
anything
this is actually the the native gamecube
version just running on a nintendo wii
through uh
an hdmi so it is like 480p
which was the most that we could do
or the gamecube rather it's the most the
game you could do was 480p
progressive scan so i've got like a uh
it's like the hdmi like a little hdmi
converter for the wii
that i use for to capture everything
and um
yeah unfortunately this one uh dolphin
emulators to play owl racing
what why did they not tell you about
this stuff
oh my goodness uh but yeah dolphin
emulator does not run this game well
which is it's very sad because chamber
of secrets looks phenomenal running on
the dolphin emulator i mean phenomenal
that's uh if you if you've seen my let's
play of chamber of secrets i'm using
dolphin emulator for that one
just because of how
it's a lot easier to capture too you
know i don't have to worry about setting
up the wii like right now i have i have
the wii hooked up sitting on the side of
my desk and the wii is always kind of
weird even when you're playing gamecube
games because you have to
you still have to use the wii remote
when you um
first turn it on to like navigate the
menu get the gamecube
all right so let's see can i just run
over and
do that really oh i think you have to
destroy them all before you can
again i feel bad for the doxies here
like the bites are poisonous but they're
literally just trying to protect uh
protect their young i mean
they're trying to protect us from
stealing their eggs
[Music]
i just saw it let me lock on but oh come
on
why are you like deflect oh right here
oh no harry's dead now too great oh yep
that's just great are you kidding it
puts me all the way back by the flying
seahorses
oh my goodness why i guess because
that's the last time the game
loaded fortunately we do not have to get
the dragonflies again it did save that
much
but we do still have to make our way all
the way back over there
oh
my goodness this poison's really oh dude
you can actually like walk through here
oh hermione's actually poisoned too they
so not only do they they die
they remained poisoned
and it starts me back way over
here can we
see what happens oh it won't let you go
in the water i was like i gotta know if
i can uh just jump in the water here
harry can you please
can you please just just move
i will give you actually no i won't
because you don't have any potions
you don't have any potions
so i'm not going to give you any
antidote whatsoever you're going to take
yourself right back up here
and we're going to take out these doxies
excu
we're gonna go back we're gonna take out
these doxies we're gonna get one egg we
literally need one egg and then we can
be done with this then we can move on
and go to snape and
build whatever potion he's wanting us to
build this time that apparently it only
goes to hermione to use at least that's
how it worked last time when we had a
potion class with snape
we have to get more doxy eggs
do we run like you you should know this
i'm really hot in these rocks yes me too
man
me too
but because you guys can't fire flopindo
at a couple of doxies then we have to
keep coming back here
i also want to know like how come
sometimes they deflect them like this
like look at look at ron hermione
they're just like hey we're just gonna
go all in
we're just literally gonna go stand
right here
get back
no way i did not get poisoned right
there i better not have it
yep sorry ron i'm not worried about your
antidote too good
i'm
stupid
okay come on
that one is occupied with ron okay
finally got that i really need some
antidote now
there we go all right finally okay if
one of these doesn't work
that's it
oh my gosh thank you
thank you
all right so now can we go back to
let's see where we need to go probably
just straight to potions right yeah go
to potions class to mix the
girding potion
all right back we go
we've got all our ingredients i really
really need some antidote now
oh okay ron you know what if you have an
antidote on you
if you have an antidote on you okay i
will
i will use it for you sir and you know
what i'll go ahead and use this one too
i really really need something there you
go there you go take your antidote
and then let's go ahead and give you
this one too let's give you the wiggin
weld don't get me wrong i like it nice
and sunny all this running around is
making me really hot okay now
let's go to
here why does harry not have any potions
hermione's got some too so let's uh
let's equip that one for her
and that one for her
she's actually not complaining about
needing
yeah so i think she's good on she may
not even need the
antidote
all right switch back to harry and
we're off
all right making our way back into
hogwarts castle gonna go down into the
dungeons
to make this girding potion which i i
have no idea what the girding potion
does
so it'll be interesting to see how
that's going to
play a role in the upcoming missions is
it going to be as annoying as the
antidote
because that one
is already worn out it's welcome with me
yo hagrid dude appreciate your help
thank you very much for the tips and now
we're gonna head back down into the
potions
into the dungeons
alrighty
and
i think it's right here
the potions classroom
wait is the sound messed up
it was for the first one
for a considerable number
number of weeks and those of you who
wish to experiment with this potion
that the maximum dosage is no more than
two of these vials
class dismissed interesting so you can
only use it
twice so is that like an upgrade like he
says it says it lasted weeks
and it's endurance i mean does that just
give them more health sorry ron i've got
to go to the quidditch stadium good luck
what draco hang on did he just leave the
plan you had about swapping the
quidditch ball crate for the one with
jinxed balls
well flint and derrick have done it they
put the real crate in the courtyard in
front of the clock tower the cubs ass
let's go wipe out gryffindor
and they just never see him they'd ever
see him there
you took your time
i've just heard that slytherin have
swapped the quidditch ball crate for one
with jinxed balls in it we've got to
tell professor dumbledore we can't just
go telling tales and expect him to stop
the match we've at least got to show him
the evidence did they say where they'd
put the real crate in the courtyard in
front of the clock tower okay let's go
outside and see if we can get into the
courtyard
let's go outside okay so back to just
where we came from right
and let's see does hermione have the
girding potion
no she does not okay so does ron have it
no all right so that one must have been
given to harry maybe harry alone has the
girding potion
all right
we just go back right where we were
all right everybody heading out for the
quidditch match
i don't see haggard here anymore
look there it is
yeah but we can't get to it from here
the only way to get to it is to go out
into the ground and then fly in or
something ah buck beak
go out into the grounds and then fly in
all right and i don't want to keep just
potions equipped for ron so let's go
pindo
and i mean we'll throw lumos on there i
don't know if we're gonna even need any
spells for this little mission here but
hey
definitely want do not want to just be
running around with the uh
potions equipped
it's so weird they would have us go
like right back to where we just were
how are we going to get into that and
then hermione yelling hurry up
i didn't even stop it i did not stop
i'm running a straight line i just i
just happen to like turn the camera
forgive me hermione for looking even
looking in another direction wait a
second
hold on this is not the right way is it
oh yeah yeah it is it's behind the trees
here
seeing the doxies over there still was
throwing me off
yep and then buck b should be in the
little pin right back
behind hagrid's hut here
there he is
all right ron give him the bow what
i pressed bow
hurry up we're going to lose the match
oh my gosh i'm pressing bell
[Music]
dude if he kicks me again
what
what is happening
okay i have no i like maybe only
hermione maybe he wants
like if i get any closer he kicks me
okay
oh my goodness like the range on that if
i was a one step closer
he loses his mind
all right so hermione's freaking out
we're gonna lose the match flies to that
courtyard yep got it got it
all right fly to the courtyard oh we're
we're timed
why are we timed on this
wait
what what
[Music]
all right i see i think it's right here
in this i
believe what
i need to get to the quidditch ball
crate
dude why are the controls freaking out
all of a sudden
[Music]
oh my gosh dude
oh my gosh
we're totally gonna have to do this
again
we're totally gonna have to do this
again
the lining up i cannot get it lined up
i can't i just can't
no
no
no
gryffindor loses oh have i mentioned the
controls in this game like have i
mentioned them at all i don't know if i
have
i don't know if i have they're
they're quite a bit wonky
all right let's try this again
i mean it started freaking out before i
even got
got to the area where the uh
so
flies to that courtyard
the quidditch supplies are
yeah yeah it's kind of like jerking like
the frames are looking really weird and
i was way away from a tree and then it
starts looking like i'm colliding with
the tree so this time i'm gonna do my
best to let's kind of take a high
approach
and then i'm just gonna try and land
like yeah nice and slow there
and go straight down
okay well
i need to get the ball crate
why can we not get it
oh wait she's just
dude i am so great i thought
there's not enough room to dismount why
not
okay now surely
we got 19 seconds we need to equip that
dragon spell
[Music]
the clock is ticking
during the load time the clock is
ticking
do we seriously have to hop up here
okay now it gave us it gave us fresh
wave of time all right oh i see it i see
it
i see what we have to do guys
so now they're they're
still giving us spells but they're
putting a time on the spells
all right luckily this one doesn't seem
too bad unless i'm i'm missing something
here which could be it is possible
all right so that dragon should burn a
little uh
what's suspending it there
all
right and we're still being timed for
some reason
there we go now to go to the quidditch
stadium
all right now to the quidditch stadium
wait why are we still being timed
oh oh wait buck b do i really are you
really gonna make me bow
i better not chance it i better not
chance it
we totally better bow just to make sure
the buckwheat doesn't get upset
all right so let's kind of angle it here
to this right side or no okay that's
fine
come on bug me get over there yes yes
okay quidditch pitch this way
one minute one minute press and hold b
to fly we are holding b
heading for the quidditch pitch
now the question is do we fly right in i
don't think so i think we're gonna have
to land right here
and then we probably go in right
okay dismount oh good perfect just
automatically triggered it
ron and hermione arrived just in time to
show the evidence yeah
show that evidence dumbledore
and allowed removed match to continue
this gave the gryffindor team the help
ah so they just totally skipped skip
over the quidditch like actually playing
in here
not only the game
i wonder if that's how hogwarts legacy
is going to have it because we know
quidditch is going to be part of the
world
you were fantastic and
i reported a few weeks ago that uh
it's not going to beat your playable
quidditch
couldn't help him at least according to
some sources that i've heard from
something you can do the time sorry i'm
just getting caught up in this moment
here with the aggregate no run along and
turn in i gotta go and make beaky
comfortable maybe we could
travel back in time
hagrid's right
there's really nothing we can do
we should turn in dude harry looks like
legitimately upset right there
if you wish to stop exploring no i don't
think i want to stop exploring actually
i think i want to try
if we go back to the castle i want to
see if we can
get the
oh what was it dragon height gloves now
or if defense gets the dark arts if that
classroom is still completely locked off
but yeah
quidditch is going to be part of the
world in the game it's they're not going
to just ignore it so i think it's going
to be interesting to see
if they find a way to incorporate it
into the story even if we aren't
necessarily playing quidditch
like a lot of people were wanting you
know like you can try out for the team
and you can be on the team and do the
practices and all that kind of thing
but if we if we go to a match and like
something's happening
at the match where we have to
investigate something or we have to
prevent something from happening at the
match
there's a lot of cool possibilities that
they could still do
uh surrounding quidditch and we i mean
we've seen quality quidditch supplies we
know quality quidditch supplies is in
the game
all right let's make our way
back
hold on
hold on i don't think i'm in the right
spot
no definitely
definitely
not in the right spot we don't need
those we do not need the dragonflies
anymore
we can just go back in
oh yeah we were over here with the
oh yeah there's the quidditch stadium so
hold on we're gonna have to go
can we get back in that way or do we
have to go to like the very front
of course no buckwheat buckbeak's gone
again
they what they want you to do is they
want you to just hit end day i don't
think we're really supposed to be
exploring much right now but really
tired yeah of course you are ron it's
the middle of daylight and you're still
talking about i'm really tired
i'm really tired harry i had to stop the
malfoy
from using the enchanted or the uh the
cursed quidditch bald
oh goodness all right so
well we know this is gonna work we know
this will work if we go all the way back
up here
and then cross the bridge yet again
[Music]
yeah it's surprising that they don't
have some sort of uh even for a game
this old
2004 i think it was that they didn't
have a way
to summon buck b because i mean clearly
they programmed the the sort of uh
the traveling system in the game to have
buck beak help you travel faster but
you have to go to that same spot to get
him every time and then even if you fly
with him somewhere
when you get done with whatever you're
doing he's gone he's just he's went back
to his place
and you have to go back there to reset
everything but
oh you can take the little prompt away
at the bottom
let me just just let me explore
just let me
that's all i'm asking
all right let's try to go to
i think it's third floor oh wait is this
one of those dragon
no it's not
for a second there it looked like one of
those dragon statues but i didn't see
anything around to
burn with it so i didn't really know
what the point was all right so we can
go this way now
and when we first were heading out for
the day
all the classrooms were locked
unfortunately
so i'm hoping they are still locked
because i would really prefer to do this
during the day oh perfect okay that
one's open first floor transfiguration
second floor charms and then we should
have third floor
defense against the dockots
all right oh wait what is it not
is it not daytime why do we have
oh no
it is day why are they patrolling right
now
[Music]
okay fine whatever we'll deal with it
we will deal with it
please don't see me
stop shaking around here get out of
course you did
i don't wish to stop exploring game
i wonder if you can uh trick them with
the dung bombs too like we could the
troll
let's try it
let's try it ron
let's switch to your dung bombs buddy
oh
one went over one too far
hey you know the rules
i'm just getting too eager
[Music]
oh my gosh
come on just
just
just stay right here ron
just stay right here
okay now
go this way
just yeah look away if you look away he
will not see you
okay wait for it
wait for it
please don't see me
step away
and okay get around get around get
around
please don't see me statue
i'm gonna wait for him to go back
because he's probably gonna be yeah he's
right there
as soon as he turns around to go back
though and the statue is
okay he's gone now as soon as the statue
and we are gone man we are gone
okay wait is this how we get to
i really hope this is how we get to
defense against the dark arts though
okay yeah it is pretty sure it's this
room right here isn't it
yes okay in we go
all right now we are on the lookout for
dragon hide gloves
could be anywhere in this classroom oh i
think i see them already
i think i see them oh and that looks
like a secret passage right here that
maybe ron's gonna be able to interact
with
we'll try it after we grab these
super perfect
return to the notice board for more
house points
and then let's see can you
okay that is definitely something
there's nothing more to do i think it's
time there's nothing more to do you
don't know that harry you don't know
that
oh man all right so let's go back out
we'll have to sneak by that guy again
but i do want to get back to gryffindor
and
turn it in although you know what like
if i just
wait what did he just say about the
girding potion
see if harry has it
no so who the heck has
who has the girding potion
because we absolutely
did we not make one
let's see how many ingredients it shows
we have the max ingredients and actually
we have the max ingredients for that too
i don't get it man i don't get it
but yeah i was wondering if we hit end
of day from right here then let's try it
let's test it out let's go ahead and hit
the end day right now
and then hopefully it will start us back
in the gryffindor common room house
point
oh yes house point update let's go
dumbledore
slytherin
ravenclaw i think we already had more
than that
gryffindor
ah yes up to 350.
is in the lead
harry ron and hermione paced the
gryffindor common room worried about all
right so we're in the gryffindor common
room now to execute buckbeat tonight
we've got to go and see hagrid he can't
just sit there on his own waiting for
the executioner you're right let's go
all right let me start right there
though yes
that's one thing the whole time i can't
wait to see how hogwarts legacy handles
that
that right away boosts up to
360.
we're wasting too much time are you
kidding me hermione are you are you
actually serious right now
guys i think that's gonna be a good
stopping point for today we'll pick up
next time with hagrid and buckbeak
gonna try and see if we can come up with
a way to save buckbeak and you guys
already know once that scene there kicks
off then we are headed for the end game
or at least you know the the sequence of
events that leads to the end game for
prisoner of azkaban so we'll see how
much longer we have in this maybe one
two more episodes i'm thinking maybe
three if we do a little bit more free
roam we'll just have to kind of see how
it goes but uh really love and and
appreciate all the support on these
let's plays lately uh give it a like
before you go that'll help other people
find the video and as always guys thank
you all so much for watching i'll talk
to you again soon